alors on s'est rencontré sur les réseaux
sociaux il est venu à moi il m'a
approché il m'a envoyé un message et
puis on a commencé à échanger voilà par
par message et puis très rapidement on
est venu à se rencontrer il m'a proposé
qu'on se rencontre au restaurant
ce qu'on a fait voilà j'ai passé un bon
moment globalement
c'était ouais très beau
et c'est voilà présenté comme un
entrepreneur qui travaillait dans l'or
et les diamants
voilà on a passé un bon moment et puis
il m'a très rapidement suite à ce
rendez-vous expliquer qu'il voulait
quelque chose de sérieux avec moi qui
voulait s'engager dans une relation
exclusive moi aussi je recherchais du
sérieux à ce moment-là donc
je connais avec buffet à volonté
je connais le bail à partir de quand tu
t'es dit qu'il y avait un quelque chose
qui était un peu chelou alors très
rapidement j'ai vu des signaux d'alerte
c'est à dire j'ai vu voilà j'ai
découvert il y avait beaucoup d'argent
liquide des faux papiers des chèques en
blanc qui n'étaient pas à son nom
il y avait deux cartes d'identité avec
sa photo dessus mais avec des noms
différents
plus compliqué attention une carte
d'identité tu t'appelles Richard
Bouchard et sur l'autre Cyril Abdoul Mac
il y a un problème
donc j'ai demandé des explications
effectivement aux éléments que j'ai
trouvé et puis bah forcément il y a
toujours répondu à tout finalement
c'était moi en fait qui était en tort
dans cette situation puisque j'avais
fouillé dans ses affaires et j'avais ça
me rappelle ça rappelle les trucs là sur
cueilli la tech tu regardes là les trucs
là tu sais les histoires là genre des
voisins tout ça là c'est les trucs là
sur TFX
petit secret en fait
on adore ça c'est vraiment les trucs à
chaque fois les mecs mais tu es fou
pourquoi tu as volé dans mes bras tu as
trouvé dans mes affaires Coralie
rien à [__] non mais c'est vrai
c'était ça donc le mec là ça a duré
combien de temps cette affaire alors ça
a duré que trois semaines ça a été assez
rapide puisque bon du coup voilà il y
avait des signaux d'alerte mais voilà
après une dispute t'as demandé de
t'acheter de lui acheter un iphone ouais
donc comment il est venu à dire ça je
sais plus voilà il y avait une dispute
et puis encore une fois c'était une ma
faute donc il fallait que je me fasse
pardonner pour me faire pardonner il
fallait que du coup je m'investre
quoi
mon engagement et pour le premier mon
engagement il fallait du coup que je
m'investisse dans l'achat d'un acteur
mais en fait j'avais beaucoup aussi de
d'emprise
comme tu avais envie de te maquiller
quelqu'un tu t'es dit bon ça je vais
laisser sa chance
affective à ce moment-là donc voilà ça a
beaucoup joué donc voilà le
de te voilà t'extorquer voilà c'était
quoi bah il a voulu que je l'achète un
iPhone bon du coup je l'ai pas fait
voilà j'ai expliqué que là actuellement
j'avais pas forcément l'argent pour
mettre des de l'argent dans un iPhone il
m'a expliqué que du coup je n'avais qu'à
faire un emprunt pour l'acheter sur un
an quoi
je n'ai pas fait non plus et puis en
fait au même moment
et donc au même moment en fait
je les avais une carte bancaire que je
retrouvais plus j'ai trouvé plus chez
moi enfin c'était bizarre et puis je
viens voilà checker ce compte que je sur
lequel je ne vais jamais et je vois
qu'il y a des prélèvements qui ont été
faits qui ont été faits dans des
commerces qui sont aux alentours de où
il habite et il y a un prélèvement aussi
sur une société à son nom donc je fais
facilement la relation entre les
événements et je comprends que c'est un
escroc alors tu te rends vite compte
qu'en fait tu es pas la seule victime
oui effectivement parce que du coup je
commence un petit peu à en parler sur
mes réseaux sociaux et puis je fais
notamment un Tik Tok et je me rends
compte que ce Tik Tok fait beaucoup de
vues et que dans les commentaires il y a
des centaines de victimes en fait qui
ont été est-ce croqués par cette même
personne et sans peine et est-ce que à
ce moment-là à ce moment-là de la
relation comme tu t'es attaché et il y
avait une certaine passion et une
dépendance affective est-ce que tu as
quand même réussi à ressentir le
sentiment de jalousie par rapport aux
autres femmes ou est-ce que tu t'es
détaché directement alors quand j'étais
dans la relation bien sûr qu'il y avait
de la jalousie même si tu savais que
c'était un escroc tu as quand même été
dans la relation et quand je ne savais
pas parce que c'était un village
psychologiquement en tout cas alors s'il
y a eu un petit choc post traumatique je
dirais
mais j'ai pas souffert en fait de la
peine de que la relation se termine mais
voilà de la du contexte en fait dans
lequel ça s'est passé et du coup ça
marche
[Musique]
actuellement il a
incarcérées
et donc une carie donc elle est dans une
endroit où elle ne peut pas sortir
forcément j'ai eu des copains de la DR
PC
je l'ai compris
un petit peu disons c'est larcin au sein
de l'établissement pénitentiaire
et donc
du coup ouais il est il a un cœur serré
mais alors il a pas été mis sous écrou
par rapport aux arnaques mais par
rapport à une autre affaire avec une de
ses ex-compagnes du coup
pour qui il y a eu du Revenge porn et
voilà on a perdu combien toi au total
alors moi il a volé ma carte et il ne
pouvait faire que des paiements sans
contact donc voilà c'était un montant
qui s'est arrivé à du 200 300 euros et
il a pas pu aller très loin voilà je
suis
jamais donné voilà juste tu t'es rendu
compte qu'il avait arnaqué des centaines
dedans parce que je vois les des
casquettes on dit les autres victimes il
a fait quoi ben les autres victimes elle
me raconte voilà des situations qui sont
un peu comme la mienne il y en a qui
sont allés malheureusement un petit peu
plus loin elles sont là il y a eu plus
de manipulation que que la mienne il y a
eu des crédits à la consommation qui ont
été faits il y a voilà des jeunes filles
qui lui ont qui leur ont donné leur
carte de crédit voilà il était
totalement libre avec il y a eu de
l'argent qui a été prêté voilà ce type
de plaintes oui oui il y a des
cinquantaines de plaintes voilà puis moi
aussi j'ai porté plainte mais c'est
difficile à prouver c'est c'est de
l'abus de confiance
moi c'est difficile à prouver qu'il m'a
volé ma carte en fait finalement pour
moi
lui a donné est-ce que c'était constaté
tu en as pris le son alors depuis moi je
me protège beaucoup plus par rapport à
quel je fais
on a le droit de demander sur quel site
c'était ou pas oui
et voilà moi je fais beaucoup plus
attention et je sais maintenant que en
fait j'ai toujours senti finalement que
il y avait quelque chose qui clochait
mais
la dépendance et la manipulation était
plus forte
je commence une histoire tout ça on va
laisser sa chance au produit
j'attends l'amour de mes rêves et donc
et donc aujourd'hui tu te tu fais comme
ça mon instinct quand je sens pas
quelque chose j'y vais pas
là
maintenant voilà je vis ma vie
voilà mais ça va mieux maintenant j'ai
j'ai tourné la page comment tu as su
qu'il était incarcéré parce que j'ai été
euh
en fait du coup grâce à mon Tik Tok
j'étais en relation avec plusieurs
victimes
du coup
je donc j'étais en relation avec une
victime notamment qui a porté plainte et
bah ça procédure à à fonctionner puisque
voilà j'ai pu aller à son audience et
j'ai donc c'est en cours il y a pas tout
qui a été rejeté non plus c'est en cours
c'est pour une autre affaire oui c'est
ça depuis vous avez après remonté la
pelote il fait quelqu’un qui a fait ça
pendant des années avant ou pas
toute sa vie et les gens que j'ai
rencontré
comment comment il arrivait à manipuler
comme ça c'est quoi c'est quoi son slip
parce que vous n'avez pas l'air naïve
comme ça donc comment il est arrivé à
vos amours tu sais oui sans doute c'est
de la manipulation et c'est ce qu'on
appelle le Love bombing c'est ce qui
explique les petits les psychiatres
notamment un psychiatre américain là
dessus et qui explique qu'en fait c'est
le fait de donner beaucoup tout de suite
aller très rapidement dans la relation
s'investir beaucoup et créer une forme
de dépendance en fait quand on rentre
dans cette spirale finalement c'est très
dur en fait d'avoir d'être clairvoyant
en fait sur ce qui se passe tu te
projettes directement en même temps avec
la personne parce que c'est agréable sur
le coup et après tu te rends compte que
c'était juste sur le coup quoi
exactement
non mais là où ils sont très fort c'est
qu'ils savent quoi faire pour pas se
faire attraper c'est-à-dire que il
demande à leur compagne de souscrire à
des prêts il leur demande de leur
acheter des choses et après ils disent
bah moi c'est ma copine qui m'a acheté
ça donc tinder qui a arnaqué plusieurs
millions d'euros il a pas mal du tout ah
oui il est tellement mais c'est vrai il
a été condamné pour autre chose
il faudrait que la justice reconnaisse
davantage la manipulation qui se voit
par message par SMS et qui puisse les
condamner plus rapidement parce que la
manipulation elle est évidente
pas trop choqué et que ça va aujourd'hui
je te dis j'ai les copains du split il
va te déférer la semaine prochaine
d'accord